the two of you set up these rules for
how you were going to run your John
chrism could you just summarize them for
us well you know as you pointed out
earlier Adam we were both sort of super
achievers and we knew that when we were
trying to meld these two careers
together that we had to agree that we
would in a certain sense sacrifice our
individual identities to this joint
effort and now that was the hardest part
because you know invitations would come
in and you know to give this honor
lecture that on election for many many
years we rotated them just just one
after the other no matter who got the
invitation we would rotate them or we
would get to liver joint lectures now I
think we're at the end where we're sort
of getting separate invitations like the
one to the symposium that you ran but
but in the beginning it was tough
especially because Joe had more of a
reputation than I did he had published
an important paper on cholesterol and
heart attacks when he was in Seattle as
a geneticist so he was already known in
the field of in the heart disease field
and I was not known at all so I think it
was very important that and if you look
back at all of our early papers we just
totally rotated first authors and last
authors you know and that's hard for a
lot of people I think that's where most
partnerships come apart because you know
they fight for credit or four or four
you know applause I mean one thing I
think Joe and I share is that you know
again it sounds self-serving but but we
really can we really do our experiments
for
our own internal satisfaction and not
for external applause I think it's
really I feel so sorry for some
scientists I know are really great
scientists but they judge their progress
by you know how many papers they publish
in high-profile journals or how many
invitations they get or what people say
about them they're trying to impress
somebody else and one nice thing about
having a partnership is you I'd only
have one person to impress and that's
him and I think it's vice versa so so it
frees us up from from some of those
pressures so the two always tell people
that ask about partnership said to
occupational diseases of long-term
collaborations like we have one is on
astigmatism if you don't see eye to eye
on the big picture then you're in
trouble okay that's one thing we do
argue about details but we definitely
pretty much agree on the big picture in
like I'll tell a fellow to do an
experiment when it has advice a certain
way and Michael suggest another way and
the smart ones will do it both ways and
then probably the world works and they
come out with a better way but and then
the second one is ego Titus which mike
was referring to if you try to take
credit with between the two of us and
and say I'd thought about this and you
didn't and so for them something one of
us will have a bruised ego so that's
what we've boarded that sort of problem
and the fellows and students learned if
they try to play one of us off on the
other doesn't work so that they learned
that fairly fast
you